TK's it back okay stream is up audios
recording Aaron can I just can I do this
mic because it's like when you yeah I'd
say switch with me but that would be so
weird the other side of you no it's fine
would be OCD okay I am streaming so
let's do this we're streaming and we're
going we're going a man used 80 helium
party balloons to fly 15 miles over
South Africa is that a sport
Ohio State beats Penn State by one point
and the USC football team is staying in
our hotel in an undisclosed location in
Phoenix Arizona
this is sports without balls we are
recording live from the ATC pop-up
podcast studio in downtown Phoenix at
the all things comedy comedy festival
presented by Bud Light City scaped and
Tito's handmade vodka
Tito's what could go wrong you guys we
are in a sold-out old Bank / Men's
Wearhouse killing it already carpeting
clean how are you Trish Suhr hired foley
are you just tickled that we're sitting
in this Men's Wearhouse first of all
thank you to all things comedy for
having this it's like we're in comedy
camp in Phoenix we are just having a
grand old time here so tickled to death
we are also doing this podcast live it
is streaming on the all things comedy
youtube channel so you can also
subscribe that and see our faces right
now I actually curled my hair for you on
put an earring in you got to lower that
screen cuz I can't watch myself delayed
then watch myself and overall terrible
podcast of that happen we've got so many
people here I don't want to disappoint
Aaron and the booth Aaron go cards go
next year next go cards not the Arizona
Cardinals name but the st. Louis Obispo
Cardinals this is exciting this is
episode one 82 82 more than than a
hundred and we are we are we are
energized Arizona it's been so much fun
we have had a ball and as you all know I
have been in full she's a mess people
I'm stroking out let City real it's the
Dodgers it is right now all right so
we're recording Saturday night we'll put
this up Monday and the Houston Astros
are up two games to one
it is currently mid 8th we're going into
the bottom 8th are we multitasking right
now are we providing the greatest
podcast ever and also watching the World
Series we are we don't mess around honey
we so Trish is usually completely in
control except for right now I'm I'm a
buttery mess I don't know it's been
crazier you sing the USC football team
arrived at our hotel lobby while we were
eating last night and I thought you're
having a seizure I was facing out the
window and Aaron was facing the
elevators and she literally was doing
this weird winky like a moment I thought
she was genuinely stroking and I'm like
baby are you and I turn around I was
like it's got to be the hottest woman of
all time like I seriously believe it was
a tie and I look around and it's what 30
22 year-old giant football balls and
being the bus pulls up the entire
football team lets out and oh my god I
couldn't function I was like what and
then I stroked out and they're beautiful
and they're just eaten bags of chips and
Subway sandwiches in our lobby I just
couldn't believe alright so the best
thing and then we'll just kind of go
back and forth we don't want to
disappoint our fans but the the you I
can't believe how big they are they are
man Wang honey I've been now going up
and down in the elevators for no reason
just to talk to USC football players
this morning I was with four large
gentlemen and I said you know good luck
go get them you know beat Arizona sorry
Arizona and they're like we're joking
around and then this one guy said to
this other guy's like oh how was it how
was a phone call with Bella check this
morning which I assume was just for me
and I turned her I go [ __ ] the Patriots
and when a smaller white lady screams
that out in an elevator with for USC
dudes they were surprised they were
surprised and then we started a
conversation I was convincing all of
them to play for the New York Giants she
comes into my room because we were
prepping for the show and she goes
honey honey I'm gonna follow the follow
regime green gotta follow regime green
and i'm looking at my now on instagram
which we now follow you were Shane green
you're going to him on Twitter he only
has like 4,500 followers on Twitter so I
feel like if I keep tweeting at him like
oh he's got one that said you need and
then he was like I'm not playing for the
Giants and then I cornered him he's only
seven ten 350 and I was like if you got
drafted by the New York Giants you would
you're going you'd go to the Giants and
he was like yeah I go Plus eyes the fact
that we have no players like literally
the entire team is an injured reserve so
someone has to play for them and then he
was like I'm not playing for the Browns
I was like you'll play for any of these
you'll paper cut shake check honey he's
like I'll smile and keep it pushing so
then I kept I just saw I don't know who
the other dude was but I saw him in the
lobby not once but twice the one I said
eff the Patriots and and I just kept
saying Giants Giants was a lism was a
star I was in stalking we're all in the
same hotel I've needed Aaron so much
every time I talk to her she's armed in
the lobby I just jumped out of the
elevator I just I keep I literally keep
saying Trish what we need to also
discuss is the fact that I get really
like shy like I won't go up to someone
and be like can I take a picture or in
like everyone's like did you tell them
about your podcast
I pass Sam darn old not once but twice
he's gonna be up for Heisman if he stays
next year he's the quarterback for USC I
just read like a 10 page article on the
ESPN Magazine I passed him twice and I
was like I need I needed you to be there
too my southern ways I'm more like
somebody spun mama so they all are very
sweet to me a accent but be that like I
look like the fun mom that brings orange
slices so they're always like yeah I'll
take a picture you seem fine so that I
could have just been like you doll this
is my fine sister who needs a photo with
you I just thrown you in there so we'll
go I'll stalk them when they get back in
the morning
we've got early fine I jump came out
like it's a make-a-wish because it was
my make-a-wish is there is there a help
is there this is this isn't a good path
to go down here's here's the thing
here's the thing I would never just go
up to I guess I can I can scream about
the Patriots in an elevator but I cannot
I can't go up to Sam darn old and be
like hi I'm afraid on I know I can but I
just I needed your southern like I got
charm well it's just more they think I'm
off is what it is I don't know if it's
charm I just like she's sweet and
wandering the halls and she just learned
how to use her iPhone I like to play
dumb when I can you know it is pretty
crazy though with you guys have happily
give a round of applause to social media
well it's it's pretty crazy that I could
look up in two seconds regime greens
he's a defensive end all his stats where
he's going and now follow him and
potentially again I'm not gonna use the
word stop that seems a baby friend yeah
real close just be just a supporter yeah
it's like a booster but with less money
yeah I have a dollar and that's why
we're in the Men's Wearhouse on on a
magical Saturday night when I'm trying
to watch Game four on my laptop but it's
buffering okay eight one one two out
let's talk about the World Series okay I
didn't see this one coming
yeah went to Game one as you all know
got my LA Moscow Mule cups we won that
that
was fine game to my dream sequence
happened VIN came out and said it's time
for Dodger baseball and then the world
imploded and we lost the game well let's
back up because the last podcast we did
was two days before you went to Dodger
Stadium so tell us what that that felt
was like it was a bucket list moment it
was Africa hot it was the surface of the
Sun it was my hand to god it was a
hundred and three degrees at game time
it was the the warmest Game one of all
time yes it was high change doesn't
exist so it's weird it's just fake news
it was an amazing environment
everyone was so lovely Astros fans were
lovely and I know you've been saying so
long both I love clearly I want my
daughters to win I love my daughters but
the Astros such a feel-good story the
fans were awesome and sweet and lovely
and so excited to be there which made it
like a really great vibe which I loved
it was all the celebrities were out you
know how like they like to show they did
show Seinfeld and the whole stadium
booed he's a fan he's a Yankee fan
they're like oh yank yeah oh boy well
they do the theater just walked into the
Men's Warehouse no they gave that they
didn't do an audible look oh they gave
them it was a grind
he's a Mets fan oh well either way
that's why they doubly booed him because
Matt Smith it was a it was an audible
groan yeah so and then it kept the
camera on him and he just was like and
Peyton Manning Peyton was there with
Lady gaga this was what was sweet Lady
Gaga Lady Gaga was there and they put
the jumbotron on her and she's in a box
and she was like okay and then they put
it on Vin Scully and then you know how
humble he is honey he was like no no
like it's about the boys take the camera
off me and then they put the jumbotron
back on Lady Gaga and she was like then
then and then they kept putting it it
was really cute and they put it back on
VIN and VIN was like I'm sure like who
is that sweet woman that's trying to
dress like Marilyn Monroe which she was
she like inside an eggshell no she
actually had like Marilyn Monroe
very short white blond hair platinum
blonde and a little white tank top and
black booty shorts what about chicks
hanging out she looked precious Wow
uh-huh and when she knew there was a
baseball game going on I don't think so
I think she really looked she liked that
cop she was enjoying that all the LA
moscow mule cop i think it was really
just an Instagram post she was there I
love him Lady gaga
I love her too honey waits for go and
she could have said no she couldn't
you know she could have been like let's
give the tickets to all our die-hard
LA celebrities were there so Ken Jong
yay yeah we had Rob Lowe
Jason Bateman who these are all diehard
ticket holders that are there as much as
I say men who also have the same faces
very similar ago very similar I George
Lopez lot of comics which we love a lot
of comedians support the doors what's
the what's the woman again Mary Hart Oh
Mary Hart
she ain't afield not to move right yeah
she was in her seat both games won Mary
Hart owns four seats so what happens a
lot of she and her husband I don't know
if they have restless leg syndrome or
what the situation is I think it's
restless leg or maybe it's you know uh
you know light bladders who's to say I'm
not their physician I think they are up
and down quite a bit and Mary usually
sits right if you're watching she's just
to the right of the batter's box at home
play and marrying her husband slide down
if I'm mr. makes their kids or whoever
but they always kind of slide so they do
this fourth person shift and then at the
end of their four seats is Larry King's
seats and he literally looks like he's
turning into that eagle from the Muppets
he's just Sam Sam Thank You Aaron he's
turned to me but you know that I know
the old men's names Waldorf and Statler
but I don't know the agel thank you I'm
a big puppet head I am is all available
wondered him powers activating
so that's what he looks like sitting
there Larry can barely make it through a
whole game so I was tickled to death
he's younger than Vin Scully and looks
like he's waiting for you younger than
Scully and blue jeans
he's heaven and then his Dodger hat
looks a little make-a-wish II in a nice
way
yeah but great atmosphere it was amazing
and everybody was so lovely it was just
good juju it really was and then Game
two I watched I don't want to brag but I
had to leave game two in the eighth
to close out a show at flappers in
Burbank
and let me tell you this thank you thank
you when you you know when you're a
die-hard baseball fan and you have to
you have to leave the 8th and then you
come back with two outs in the bottom of
the 11th that's what happens that's what
that's what happened I missed everything
Graham Elwood I missed I missed all the
action
there's so many people streaming and so
it's bananas and children we just sent
them with I was in the air and Delta
everyone at Delta conspired to get me to
Chattanooga because I did four shows in
48 hours yeah got me to Chattanooga
before you know first pitch and I'm so
glad they did or I wouldn't have seen
VIN say it's time for baseball and
Seeger meant well I mean I was bawling
crying my eyes out watching the
beginning of that and I was like this is
amazing that the flyover again I was
just like hearts and joy and god Bless
America and then it imploded yeah listen
the Houston back woke up George Springer
who is I love like Polebridge hope you
are ladies got a list his dad's got a
list he's from Kepler said I just love
George Springer he's not paid to talk I
just
Wow Wow Trish is apparently anti Lisp
you guys know I just you know is his
strength he's he's precious but the the
Houston bats came around that I was like
first of all I like I like well this is
what I like doing sitting in my lazy boy
drinking a beer questioning the coaches
calls and oh god what a national pastime
I wouldn't have pulled the Rich Hill why
Paul Burchill he was having a great game
think and goes in can jam goes in my
Kenley Jansen I know in like going into
the fifth form a ADA they only he's made
it for a couple batters it's not like
Rich Hill was lights out it wasn't
wanted but it was only a one run
ballgame and I and I think you have to
be prepared for what could possibly have
happened and that's the bottom of the
11th
and Brandon McCarthy well I just it was
I don't it was it was my nightmare and
you had fair for him no I mean if I have
to relive it again I'll have a stroke
okay we won't relive it ah well what
what happened was Houston won and then
yesterday before our show we met up we
watched most of it we got most of the
game in and just yeah Houston - you know
Houston right now is basically out
pitching the dog I know I did
it's one one one top of the ninth three
one I think it's time for a guest what
do you think I think it'd be great we
have this a great source of comics at
this festival and we're gonna bring up
one of my all-time favorite humans as
well as comics he is a tour de force he
he is in New Yorker I've known him since
the 60s please welcome Sean Conroy
the 60s were such a good time especially
as a tour de force yeah
just touring de forcing all around New
York City and I'm brought a wardrobe -
did you have a change mid-show I love
that honey I love a good costume change
yeah I I can't wait to put on my dress
and minute 44 so as a New Yorker let's
talk about this because this is one
thing we wanted to talk about and then
we'll talk about the Darvish girl a
scandal Oh
but which I thought what Wow her we
watch we've got you word grater let's
just talk about that right now yeah did
you see the okay cuz Dave Roberts mom is
Japanese so do you have speaks Japanese
right so Dave the the forgive me for
that I just stroked out then the
managers name Rose pinch right when he
called Dave Roberts last night and said
we don't we don't back this behavior you
have you can retaliate in any way you
felt feel free like yeah called and said
we are more brushback well it was shitty
music
he was just like enjoy because we're not
that's not who we are because I would
never disrespect you was just a class
act on his part cuz he called Dave
himself and just said look good for him
that's great we would never this isn't
who we are it's not who any of us are
and then Aaron tells me what Darvish
says and I was like just bring it up
good home write up training I didn't see
it I didn't see it during the games
right um driver says so gary l does if
you didn't see it he'd made like
terrible like slanty eyes something you
would do in third grade you wouldn't do
it in third grade not now before we were
just just slaying it um you know just in
the in the backwoods of comedy but yeah
just mean it's just terrible and i was
surprised because girls got a good story
he this is like technically his rookie
year and he's 30 like he's been around
and it's kind of a feel-good story and
he
you know was just he crapped on his own
kitchen runs Trish Suhr it's too why oh
my Bellinger doubles and a sharp line
drive to gonzales corey seager scores
Justin Turner 2/3 is currently the top
of the ninth 1-0 I am mrs. Erin honey
baby Jesus kenley jansen I'm gonna just
channel you right now just a quick side
note even if you if you're watching this
to find out what's going on in the game
there's other ways to get that this this
will air on Monday so it'll be riveting
I should go live oh my I'm sorry if you
are streaming this podcast to get the
World Series in for me you are in luck
some kind of all right Darvish this is
Darvish his response right so gharial
apologizes he goes I didn't do it to
offend anyone okay whatever
so Darvish goes out and you know
obviously was like that was
disrespectful then he says he posts this
no one is perfect that includes both you
and I what he had done today it's a
little choppy what he had done today
isn't right but I believe we should put
our effort into learning rather than to
accuse him if we can take something from
this this is a giant step for mankind
since we're living in such a wonderful
world let's stay positive and move
forward instead of focusing on anger I'm
counting on everyone's Big Love okay so
he's quoting an HBO show and a Moon
speech like come up with your own stuff
Tarver yeah come on it's just he's he's
so awesome he's like so I'm sorry that I
threw the ball and it hit Deadwood but
next thing you know he'll be singing
soprano and then he's gonna have like
the natural the lightning bolt right on
his it's gonna be a Harry Potter slash
lightning bolts really came down to the
wire Thank You Erin thank you I just
went live on insta story in case people
want to get their score of the game but
you know we're doing the all things
comedy pod
quit honey turn on Trish's insta stream
the game is on buck
we've got Trish and Erin do you realize
there's no out you guys it's a tough and
that's the top and we're stuck in a
podcast studio getting this on dial-up
well I hope they have some women's suits
for sale after this podcast I really
thought if I really thought we were
beyond this kind of racism but I guess I
just have to dream a little dream and if
people are tuning in we're doing our all
things nominee podcast Oh God
you kind of feel like you know sometimes
you're just eastbound and down and
you're just trying to get back up and
you know I don't know I don't know what
he was thinking maybe I can't ever get
inside the mind of a married man hey
whoa Erin Curb Your Enthusiasm we're
gonna do puns for the next we're gonna
kill it honey I blame myself I'm sorry
anybody wants an update
worldwide we've got no outs and runners
excited Bank oh my gosh
Joseph big bang
stalking the USC football team so
Jarmusch's response was obviously
completely amazing and so it was
forgiving busy and saying let's rise
above this yes which is is there a show
called rise above this no no I'm done
with I didn't know if we had going do
you think he would have even seen it
because it was a dugout can't have
someone shooting into the dugout after
the home run woody but you're doing it
on purpose he was blowing the guy yeah
looks like you doing it to another
player like it doesn't matter at the end
of those I'm good
obviously you're at the World Series
there's 6463 cameras there's like one
for a cleat there is a cleat camera
you're going to be on camera oh yeah so
you know at any moment it's like it's
like assuming that you're not gonna be
seen it now makes it not don't get me I
will hop on a soapbox about this hateful
mess what
but but I don't disagree with that but
it's also not about whether or not it's
gonna be on camera it's like why is
somebody still it's doing this was you
were okay to do this period does it
matter
the world's biggest stage and the sports
[ __ ] you play you just decided being an
[ __ ] it was a good thing to do at the
racist and so he gets five games next
year he's a five game suspension in 2018
which is going to sting and yeah because
every game matters did you hear the
reasoning behind that cuz I'm I
understand Dave Roberts at one of my
like betta bees nest and it really
wasn't up to them but they asked the
Dodgers you know their thoughts on the
matter and Yu Darvish this response was
what caused them to do it next year and
I thought really that's what caused you
to do it next year although I have to
say they were gonna pile the whole team
I don't think you I don't think you
suspend someone a World Series game for
that it's not a game issue it's a moral
issue exactly you bring it up like this
is all it's been out there I'm glad it's
out there I'm glad you know what I mean
but I just I do think also people are
idiots people are gross they make
mistakes you know I don't think
suspending him for a World Series game
would have been the right decision I
just hope he doesn't get to do a
commercial where he says I'm not a role
model yeah yeah no he won't because he's
now completely in a terrible light and I
will never get a haircut that is
suspension worthy that hair is just
terrible mural uh let's talk about this
Girardi sure are fired fired what are
your thoughts about that I'll tell you
Mike now we had we would I pull it up
there yeah we had a fun we've something
yeah chime in about that or just wanting
to get my response off unfair fun well
we have so many fun fans but this was
from Sarah Kay who reached out to us on
our Facebook page and she said hey
please tell me the next episode will
have a classic Aaron Foley monologue
detailing her
and history of the New York Yankees her
feelings about Girardi both as a player
and manager her reaction to his exit and
her thoughts on the future of the baby
bombers which of course will be followed
by a classic Trish Suhr monologue Ari
the Yankees branding strategy for the
next three to five years
classic monologue coming yeah you know
we have we have a lot of stuff going on
so I think it's gonna be it may be a
longer classic monologue but here I'll
give you my reaction and first of all
thank you so much for emailing us I
gasped I it was so unexpected and so out
of left field if you will that I
literally go huh that was my that's the
right analogy so out of the leash so
wide right I just I know any any logical
explanation that I I read an article
like that day and it was like it was
just it was 10 years and it was just
simply time for him to go know it's had
time for you to go you come within outs
within innings away from you into the
world's really turned the culture around
at the Yankees wouldn't you say like
really kind of brought them we have a
very young team but I would say I don't
what do you mean by coach well I think
it got like it became it I would like to
say fresh it like it was like a refresh
I think he took a young team and made a
great job yeah a fresher team where
Yankees because they are so steeped in
so much history and it was a lot of the
Steinbrenner ways and that kind of vibe
so after well he's been there I see her
saying two thousand nine eight nine it's
ten years but I I do think that he was
being spoken of in the in the make
possible manager of the year for taking
you know and then we've got you know you
also have to handle Frazier Robertson
Canley coming in midseason bird is
supposed to be your first baseman we
don't get him back to like late
September all these moving parts then
you bring in who's the dude not holiday
but the other dude that didn't work out
in first base not Alonso they
he was in the beginning the c.carter
Chris Carter Chris Carter nowhere to be
found
yeah showrunner of the x-files show okay
well that makes sense now why he didn't
work it's bases-loaded Trish by the way
it's 2-1 bases loaded
my phone is buffering I just I just
don't I don't get it I get here's the
thing back phone if Girardi gets fired
because they have this like heir
apparent or second coming of Jesus or
someone that they put in right away and
they go we've been grooming him we feel
like you know it was a shitty seat like
there's no now everyone it's a guessing
game on the internet a guessing game of
who will now take over so if they're not
grooming someone its Mattingly available
Oh God we're never gonna we're not
getting Mattingly Jeter will fire him
though
well we'll have someone else there's to
be fire fire him but I just know I'm a
gift basket and he will give him my
thoughts just just as a counterpoint
when I was growing up with the Yankees
every other day Billy Martin was being
fired and Bob lemon was being hired yeah
yeah kind of a nice throwback to the
days when you didn't know who the next
manager was yeah yeah no it that was
mentioned it was just like you know
there's obviously ten years is a lot for
Yankees or so yeah I just I don't know
him within outs of going to the World
Series yeah like what do you want him to
do there's no way you fire him to fire
somebody like that like what grounds do
you have did they have to pay him a
bonus if you say longer yes he was up
for he you know his controversial fired
like Tuesday so I can't
I hate doesn't like saying I on the
other hand stare at myself like I'm a
small child in a mirror huh okay all
right well think about it from Girardi's
point of view where he's like what the
[ __ ] do I have to do
oh well that's true sir you're gonna be
very happy what just happened we scored
again just happened was in play runs
details coming moment three three one
three two one
fielder 3-1 Dodgers top of the ninth to
out tiny baby Jesus if you could make
this happen and we've got cárcel
tomorrow night and I'll be home for Game
six boys don't worry I'll bring the
orange sauce we night what are you gonna
go ask super forever bad
I might actually paint my whole face
like a baseball while we're talking
about
so anyways Sarah the answer your
question is I I'm gonna drop an f-bomb
okay I can't [ __ ] believe they fired
him to us
classic Foley monologue Wow can I who do
you think they're bringing in some of
the names being thrown around dude are
not better than Joe Girardi Tony pain
yeah will he be good at nobody knows the
first base coach
I don't know then they said Kevin long
the hitting coach for the Mets who was
the hitting coach for the Yankees when
we weren't [ __ ] hitting his Lasorda
available Oh bless wait Tommy I swear
y'all let me tell you something these
Dodgers have to win because the second
they win he is gonna just quit like I'm
not when I salute him at the game by the
time he's yanked to sweet self up the
innings oh like he's like just crawling
up to Y hey we'll all be there someday
God willing
no God willing I mean in heat but he got
up in God willing I will I will manage
the Dodgers one day oh you know what you
may learn or just God willing and the
creek don't rise let's put a pin in
baseball and then we'll get back to it
okay because we have Shawn here and
Shawn and I have bonded over I'm just
gonna say it one of the world's greatest
teams the New York knickerbockers and we
have been oh so bad it's been it's been
a long time this is what happened it's
been a long time see if you believe this
theory okay one of my all-time favorite
players number 20 Alan Houston yes so
great right we give him a hundred
million dollars we never win again so
you think he should have gotten only 99
million you should have gotten 40 we
should have built the biggest contract
in the NBA at that time the worst the
worst yeah
was just crazy and it was a reward for
stuff he had already done not really
yapping towards the future yeah that's
when I think it all went wrong 100
million dollars to Ellen he's all by
that and that was a long it was in 9899
because they were in the finals in 99
that was the strike shortened season
with Latrell Sprewell well got worse
free well Stark's oh well right I mean
that was when I became a mixed family
early Peterson home run dashboard
foresight scores baby joc 6y Dodgers
again if you're getting this information
from here there are other places to get
it that are more so never more amazing
human sitting here right now during me
and this was the hardest once we
realized the time we were podcasting
today I almost had a mini so just like
seizure I was like can we call in sick
we sub out that's always the worst when
you're like [ __ ] I have to do this oh
yeah and I love doing this doing this
and I thought oh my gosh and they can we
get it you know due to being at the you
know Joseph Fairbanks I didn't have a
full TV set up in here maybe Jack you
know I love when like little little
things happen oh and it comes back it
was like second or third inning
cuz jock has been starting not starting
starting at they're stunning and he goes
into hit and like the second or third
inning and I don't know Joe
whoa I can't even say his name I can't
stand him I he I think was bucker
Smoltz was like oh the manager sorry
sorry I just had a moment what's the
manager's name Roberts
Dave Dave Roberts sticking with jock
Peterson showing his faith in Jacques
Peterson you know when you hear those
little things you just and then Olson
three-run homer
I mean this turns out Roberts knows
what's up
Hey look he was think about it 2004 with
Big Papi they came back and won three in
a row was one of the world
talk about that Carrigan I don't want to
talk about oh when I moved to LA and I
was living over on the Sunset Strip yeah
didn't know anybody here didn't know
anything and I was going to the saddle
ranch every night to watch the game and
I was like and I was like breaking up
with my girlfriend on the phone at the
same time as I was watching was a
nightmare it was the worst base path I
wanted to kill them but what great like
what a great human being though she'd be
driving them home right now yeah
WeHo god willing and my husband's
texting me obscenities this is and when
we only talk in bitmoji 'he's my
husband's taking a vow cell with
celibacy during the playoffs so have you
gone along with that well I've had no
choice and I told him we better get it
together cuz I'm like they're not gonna
put you in you don't need to be stored
up which is a myth anyway you all know
that I've gone in the opposite direction
I am just banging my way through the
playoffs okay wait Knicks well I have
you there four games into the season I
have yet to watch a game they won their
first game last night which they were
the last team in the NBA to win a game
this season one is not looking good
porzingis dropped 30 he's to die for me
too yeah they need to just make sure
that he gets to do what he wants but he
doesn't get overplayed yeah
like that that would be my biggest
concern right now yeah is don't wear out
the zinger I've got you need to make
that but seriously because he's good
enough that they could play him yeah 48
minutes a game yeah you know and and and
really and try to do well but they need
to just like yeah let him play 35 37
that's a game that we gave Hardaway 48
hundred billion dollars for him to be
medium on the bench but here's the name
I'm going to throw out and it's Doug
McDermott hmm Doug McDermott I was a
super fan of when he played at Creighton
he he was he was that college kid that
broke like every shooting record ever he
got drafted I think like 10th or 11th in
the draft like three or four years ago
and just basically no one's given him a
real shot
I forget who he was initially maybe
Chicago or African who we went to year
one but he's Doug McDermott by the way
being the best shooter at Creighton is
like being the best Cub Scout like it's
not except that he broke every rock and
like all these he broke Doug Dickey went
so good no nuggets
Denver okay then maybe Chicago now he's
he's played and and people were saying
that Knicks are so bad why cuz he was
killing it in the NBA like d-league so
you're saying just give him the rock and
what he's worth 20 the other night like
I'm telling you like he is going to he's
gonna be I think fun to watch because
McDermott's got like this NCAA record
it's like number one in scoring or
number two in scoring or something like
that he's I mean it was Creighton but he
still literally shot the lights out and
Creighton he brought quite into like NC
double-a finals a couple times
Carol let's do a quick Carroll update Oh
Carol is in Phoenix people we've been
getting requests carols carols our fact
checker okay and she's a drinking
problem she really likes leans towards
the bones farm so she's got a certain
yeah she also takes Capri Sun and
doctors it up well and I have been
together now for I mean not you know
that gathers not just business-wise for
six or seven years now and I hadn't
mentioned her the last couple months
because she was on the road with her in
Vegas uh just counting cards she's here
she's she's a little late she's a little
late I'm not gonna lie she was supposed
to be here when we started but she'll be
here so thank you for asking Thank You
Carol
Carol's doing great she's a hot [ __ ]
mess she's fine she's excited be in
Phoenix uh can we just can we just call
an audible and just have you up
here and bring Eleanor up to just
inaudible Eleanor Carrigan this this
woman this woman from the line Foley
calls inaudible she showed inaudible cuz
I enjoy everyone on this dais
you sure did drop dead you just halved
the audience by the way that's the big
reveal by the way one out bottom of the
ninth
Jansen's in oh come on can jam let me
properly introduce eleanor Kerrigan I
this woman is one of my favorite comics
alive okay she did so she did a sports
without balls show with me probably at
least a year ago and we talked about
Philly fandom we talked about your days
wrestling I used to be a wrestler stop
it right nut wait somebody stop it right
audience man we can eliminate them all
wait okay I have so many questions yeah
you want to google it Carol usually does
that Oh
when Trish and I were kind of prepping
we are talking about questions which
we're gonna ask you guys like and and we
briefly during our fun luncheon today we
were talking about teams but this goes
right into what Trish and I were talking
about earlier how you follow like you
follow certain teams but you were
talking today about you're following
players players so talk to us about that
I grew up in a really small South Philly
roll home and I have nine brothers and
sisters six boys three girls so one
television so all I know are sports yeah
my dad left but he no like sports
anyways I won't need him [ __ ] that guy
okay and kill weird anyway different
kind of guy but yeah so he let but we
had the one TV so it's all we watched
and we're in South Philly so most of my
brothers were you know run numbers if
you will yeah it's not your business but
that's what they understand and so we
had Mike we used to turn my mom's house
into a sports book we'd have like a
little TV
Sacco they'd have the radio going my
mother's like Jesus Christ yeah we're
all cursing because it was never just
about the Philly teams because when you
gamble you get everything
it's who's making you know I mean they
bet on coin toss they bet on every
single thing you think of amazing
anything you can think of they gambled
on which cube of sugar is the flaw in
Atlanta so and my mom is a big Flyers
fan like huge hockey she loved the Broad
Street Bullies she actually took us to a
game because we had such a terrible and
I think is the story but can you tell it
again because this is one of my all-time
favorite sports stories yeah because she
was the first of all she's amazing my
mom I don't know how she even talks to
me but she is awesome and she loved
flyers and it was one night was a
terrible storm in Philadelphia nobody
could the only the teams got there the
day before is the only reason they were
there and the flowers were playing I
believe st. Louis and I was like five or
six so she took all of you well on the
radio they said if you can get to the
stadium if you can get to so the
spectrum will let you in for free and
will give you hot dogs and hot chocolate
my mom was like wrap him up kids no
money
her husband's a typewriter she's like
did she and she had two little ones
Bobby and Nene were too little to go so
I had to be four or five they've been
five I think five and so it was the end
of the Broad Street Bullies kind of
thing because it was 77 or 76 around
that era and so we my mom put us on a
sled me and Billy were the little ones
so we were on the sled holding each
other
so in snowdrifts joint who could barely
get out the front door that's how bad it
was I love your mama right we live a
mile from the stadium and Johnny and
Charlie are nine and ten and their Rick
McLeish Reggie leach they're beating
each other up over who's better man I'm
like they're on the same team guys we're
all gonna work this out
and so we go it's a mile my mom we lost
my brother Billy for a while
I was like mom check the trips hurry up
you're gonna be short a hot dog oh I
know we saw my dog for a minute we
shouldn't be out and I'm because my dog
was a wanderer because because there's
too many people in the house and there
wasn't enough food she's like I'm gonna
find something else so many TVs on it
here you guys are crazy
no one's even petting me I'm leaving so
she was well I was like oh [ __ ] that's
fluffy and my mom was like she'll be
fine let's go yeah so we get there
there's about 20 people in the spectrum
in the stands like so we were at the
glass and I remember my mom always tells
the story but like I saw it a different
way she so it's me that I grew up in a
different area because I see she's like
you always tell lies I'm like it's not a
lie I remember Billy doing this and what
happened was Bobby Clarke
checked this guy against the glass and I
remember his nose like went wrong
it's just splatter you know what they
used to fight all the time and I saw the
blood nose like yeah yeah daddy this is
all me and I was like excited and my
brother Billy was just staring at Bobby
Kirk who a tilted his head like he doing
and Bobby Clarke looked at him and
smiled
that's my mom's version I swear I swear
that Billy was looking at him like this
and then he went oh and he fainted cuz
he went down I remember having to pick
Billy up your brother yeah he went down
he was so nauseous from what but my mom
said that Bobby Clarke was looking at
this little boy like why are you beating
him up so she might have a better memory
because I was like yeah but I like her I
just remember Billy like faint it felt
like yeah it's like he went down like
whoa because he had a weak stomach he
was a wolf everybody's entitled to their
own perception of the world both of your
memories are valid thank you I'm says
I'm a liar no embellishment we say in
our family also like Trump's doing a
great job you know there's all kinds
alternative the LA Dodgers have beaten
the Houston Astros
tell you about peterson - hell yeah -
two days Thank You Giancarlo tomorrow
night right he's no he's not a rookie
this is his third third okay but we come
young junk we call baby Jess yeah in his
rookie season he was terrible he just
figured him out quick so the pitcher he
got figured out real quick they had a
tween to really bring in and he had a
terrible regular-season he got hurt yeah
so it was just a lot he really went
through it so this is a big deal because
like you just said Roberts didn't
quitting so this is just true that's
true and my nephew plays for the
Minnesota Twins he's in their farm
system Jimmy Kerrigan don't know we'll
follow him so he's going to spring
training so I don't know where he's
gonna go next but you know that's how
they do it yeah but right now he's been
killing it so I'm so happy but he was
[ __ ] on he got a terrible year
anything you know he's not doing
anything I could do better than that you
know we're all each other and so he's
like I can do better than that and as he
was arguing I was on the phone my mom
hit home run it was the game one yeah no
he's killing him the postseason what
he's doing yeah Roberts showing his
faith in him yeah Sean that's exactly
what's happening I can't wait to see
mine I asked questions for you guys but
I've just an errand cuz I my uncle was
an assistant in the NBA my entire life
so I got to be around sports more than
probably a normal person and I got to go
to a couple NBA Finals oh wow
young and appreciative don't get me
wrong but not to the level that this is
hitting me now cuz I grew up in Kentucky
with no professional sports teams
so I've all my teachers so I am a huge
obviously a huge Dodger fan and I'm a
Patriots fan that's my disgusting I
guess I'll see you guys look Bella Chari
let me say why my dad was just
my dad was a Jets fan and there's also
disgusting he hated the Patriots hmm and
so I felt Bethan when I was a little cuz
I they seemed all-american to me it was
like Patriots right so as a small child
that red white and blue
Patriots this is my mom used to comb the
guys what the cute has what so that's
why joining shot her around the world
so my question both of you is what would
be or bringing up the dog bucket list
sports moment bucket list sports to go
to Ohio to like if you could go but I
would have have to be pride back and you
mean back in time know if you could go
to anything do you want to do one for
the back I'm afraid to go to games but I
will say those that might I was a
football player I was a quarterback when
I was young and I play Pat at football
cuz I didn't know it was a girl
told like a week ago so I did it was my
brother's fault and I played and I
hadn't knew a girl till last night right
we never met before
and I was like look at this okay too
much too much hey Caitlin put your pants
back on so I I had a cannon right and so
I kind of got out of it you know you get
in to start liking boys cuz I'm not
smart and then I start you know dating
so you kind of weaned off it but I was a
very athletic kid and I always wanted to
have a like a kid a son and have a
quarterback so he wouldn't have to be
hassled because girls weren't we don't
let girl playing holy school we're gonna
hurt her so I had to kind of you deal
with all that but I did have one good
friend that stayed and she killed it she
played all the way up till College
awesome yeah that's awesome but i didn't
i [ __ ] down I was like and so yeah and
so which is fine and then so I stopped
doing it and I wanted to have a kid and
my first fiance my first ex-fiance I
have a few of them I love this his uncle
played for the Brooklyn Dodgers shot
heard around the world
and it was Ralph Branca the pitcher
wildin Dodgers what so I was like oh my
god I'm gonna have my [ __ ] kid with
the cannon our dream seeker sure yeah
that would have been my ultimate sports
watch the kid that I I'm sorry I had to
let him go
uh I've never did it I and my ex broke
up we just I never had kids whatever but
now I have my nephew I live vicariously
so I guess the ultimate sports thing
would be watching my nephew play in the
World Series that's on any plane or pro
game if he makes it so I'll be cheering
him on majorly he's already playing pro
yeah already in the farms like it's only
you know he just has to kill it at
spring training and then they move you
around that's my goals so no matter what
team if it's not your team or not I mean
it's the other when it's someone's first
game and the parents are like I was
supposed to the audience in the crowd
and it's just like yeah just one crowd
were just like it's just so magical I
just a big call up we were there for
farmers Oh a farmer did the big walk off
it was just like a big it was such a
happen to him he's out there he's not on
that he's not on that yeah right look he
had such a great start and then they'll
keep him looking at a brand all keep him
and barn sorry we're back no no I I love
it I'm just thinking of my insane South
Philly family watching this when he when
he made the stands oh I think I just saw
their dog on the section yeah Fluffy's
he'll come back yeah she will come your
mom has to bring a sling it's gotta be
full circle oh yeah God it would be she
loves baseball too yeah she's a big
hockey baseball those are her she's like
I watch football but I don't really
understand that too much she gets lost a
little bit and the boys are gambling so
[ __ ] [ __ ] bothers her that's why I
always think good people I mean I've
said there's so many times cuz I'm so
obsessed with sports but it really it
just brings so much joy it's a little so
much pain so much joy but the ultimate
escape like when sometimes
I get you know you have to have 80 jobs
in this career and and then all Sun
dreams come true and you perform in a
Men's Warehouse and but when I think
about like stats and when I think about
games and who's pitching or you know
went deep on the Pat was watching the
Penn State Ohio State game doesn't Great
Green anger but good for Ohio State I
mean they they came back they pulled it
off I don't think about anything else I
don't think about anything else like
everything ceases to exist like your
mom's I just thinking like nah it was a
day for us 10 kids and why because one
of them was in the snow drip temper okay
Billy a few times yeah I'm fine with
people who don't watch sports but I hate
it when people are like I don't get it
you don't it's like I don't really trust
people that have never drank like I'm
fine if you don't I'm fine if you don't
right if you make it made a choice now
to drink no problem but when people say
oh no I've never drank I'm like you're
shifty you might be the President of the
United States someday you don't like
squirting away you've never tried
drinking sentence off you that's a
communist my right front row do you guys
follow players is that a weird thing to
play and then Sean I want to ask you
your bucket list the players we were
talking about today is you you know just
from Philly you think you everything
would be Philly like it is everything's
a New York but then you know la I adopt
Dodgers Clippers you know not first and
foremost but you're saying it was
Celtics because you followed Bert Oh
Larry Bird and Magic Johnson and me and
my brother Johnny used to fight terribly
over it because he loved magic and I
just loved bird but I I also love to
oppose my brother Johnny
because Lonnie's a bandwagon okay you
should be outed and I had the bandwagon
get back on the sledge
it wasn't even on this level I get them
all mixed up he um he was a big Yankees
fan and that I was like you know what
I'm gonna find out who the rival is and
it became the Red Sox and that's
fortunate Lee it was 1986 yeah so I was
like oh this is great refused a bill but
I was in right and then that I was like
this team's like me they get big it
right there and then everything falls to
[ __ ] so I stayed a Red Sox fan I still
love the Phillies my mom was a beer girl
at that Stadium for yes are the Eagles
and the Phillies like I want to fly your
mom in right now I will tell you story
like she's the ground I want my mom to
meet I want Mary Agnes Kathleen Foley to
meet oh what a great name mrs. Carey
Edith Veronica why they need their own
sports show right oh my god full name
yeah full name uh Shawn what's your can
I say a couple yeah you can do past
president first and foremost I would say
probably the Superbowl I'd love to go to
if the Giants are in the super yeah it's
gonna happen as soon as we get the
entire team back wise like the biggest
single event in sports yeah
and then another one is because I the
first sport I don't really follow it
much anymore and I'm sorry to say this
cuz we just watched you guys watch this
baseball game real-time update I don't
really follow baseball that much anymore
but when I was like four years old and
when I started going at Yankee Stadium
with my grandfather so that was my first
love of sports was the Yankees he was
that he was like a semi-pro player and
like you know so I love the Yankees when
I was a kid and then I was like oh this
is a boring sport so that would be my
second thing like a World Series game no
no sorry sorry an all-star game because
it's right my my birthday is the 13th of
July and every fuse
game is on my birthday so I would love
to go on my birth now does it have to be
at Yankee Stadium could be anywhere
that's good I almost would prefer it to
be elsewhere just because I've only been
to Yankee Stadium and Dodger Stadium I
haven't been to any other ballpark
be cool to see I've talked about doing
the stadium World Tour where we going
just because we get do breeze so cool
about half you've got about half right
now if I won the lottery I would
literally get an RV not even not even a
g6 an RV I'm aware that I could fly a
helicopter to these venues I would want
to go and just take an RV or just a
badass tour bus like I'm fado and roll
up in the parking lot and just do it
right yeah I I've gotten I've started
thinking about how I would answer that
question I thought I knew but now it's
it's sort of like I've gone to so many I
did one Yankees I did Game seven Arron
Boone which was crazy because I could
never afford a playoff game
I could barely afford regular season but
back then you could still get like a 13
$14 bleacher seat and then you knew so
many people you know and I went to
college with like really successful
white people and they didn't
congratulations I was the one that went
into the arts and you know get paid and
balloon animals welcome to the club my
friend so I did I did go see that that
was like tremendous I think Superbowl
for sure but I've gotten really and then
I would think March Madness but March
Madness to me feels accessible it
doesn't feel bucket list because I'm
gonna get there you don't even like it's
just you know I mean it's like taking
the time and it just always feels
accessible to me what doesn't feel
accessible which I think would be now on
the height of my bucket list would be
Women's World Cup soccer I did get to
see one I got the semi-finals
in the last World Cup I saw USA play
Germany
in Montreal and it was like mine boat
mind-blowing and we were talking about
the tennis today when I said to her I go
you know cuz this is to me having my
team in the World Series it's so I went
to game one and I teared up I teared up
and I like had that was this the first
World Series game you had I remember
yeah I've never been to a World Series
and and I just had that moment of and
even with before was my uncle's team's
it wasn't like I had an affinity I loved
obviously I was working we live whatever
team he played for but it wasn't like my
team right that's what when this
happened and I've had been a season
ticket holder with the Dodgers for seven
years almost seven years so we've gone
through some jenkki times and I was like
wow and I stood there and I just got so
emotional and we said today I go I don't
know like this was such a huge moment
what would it be
and I said between the final and I'm a
Kentucky fan clearly going to and it's a
final or I would want to go to all four
of them women's majors and Grand Slams
the Grand Slam because I weekend in
Wimbledon where you see the women on the
Saturday and a man on Sunday I think
that would link that would right and I
think because I've been to US Open
matches Australian Open it would just be
like if I if I was there it would be
amazing the French Open I'm not like the
biggest clay fan but growing up getting
up so early as my family to watch
Wimbledon finals although now that I'm
staring right at grim Elwood a couple
weeks I'm sorry about that we did one of
my favorite episodes our wmba that was
going to that game where they could have
won the sparks could have won the whole
thing that would have been my first
championship game of course they blew it
but it was a great game and playoff
there's something so amazing to be in
that atmosphere and that way that was
the lottery I also think you can't put
win or lose on the bucket list no just
being there I mean that's what my
husband said he goes I'm gonna sell the
tickets
what's which ones are we keeping right
and and cuts clearly it's not like we're
making gazillion dollars off the tickets
and I said we're going to get more he
goes well what's our make me not go
price and I said well what are we worth
liquid I will divorce your ass I was
like we're not go we're not going to
Game one
what are you huh and so he's solid okay
was this before or after that that he
took the valve so I feel like it was
right after he took it before but didn't
really let me know and I was I just
thought were having a dry spell turns
out from the bullpen anyway he's saving
his legs for no reason no reason no
reason let go it's just come on another
bucket listen maybe you could help me
out with it's not mine really it's my
mom she wants the Kentucky Derby she
wants go to the Kentucky she would love
it every year it is also the Kentucky
Derby there's two ways to see it
annoying the outlet hell so the infield
our little rough-and-tumble a little
more redneck 79 she'd love it
either way you drive your beers right
out of the box exactly right and you
could probably go my own yeah because
they're like the horses run by you all
day so no mud that's up that would be it
yeah you're you're right there where it
stands and the grandstands you're a
little more removed right like it's
great but you are set back so it is much
more proper but it is fantastic and it
is a hard ticket now it is yeah really
like they charge nine literally nine
hundred a night for a motel six room
that's what we were saying we'd have to
stay like you just say Lexington
I got another nephew in Ohio so we can
stay in his place he's at Kentucky he
should just I tell people just hire car
service and drive out like it's cheaper
to hire a car service to take you in and
out yeah
then stay yeah I was telling Trish last
night I actually am like Kentucky you
tell me how you acquired so this is a
very big person you want to go and like
dress up and like in a seersucker suit
oh you'd pull that option
somehow way back it up what are you yeah
okay it's an official thing it's a very
big deal in the state of Kentucky to be
a colonel you have to be asked like it
is
I'm sorry nominated by somebody else and
then you receive a Kentucky Colonel
credential which I do not have as a
Kentuckian but what is a Kentucky
Colonel
it's a completely fake title that makes
you like the colonel makes me like the
Kirk what do you mean colonel but it's
existed for a long time is the highest
title of honor bestowed by the
Commonwealth that's us
commissions for Kentucky Colonels are
given by the governor and the Secretary
of State to individuals and recognition
of noteworthy accomplishments and
outstanding service to a community state
or the nation what did you do Roy why
what tell us this I don't want to get
into my head anymore if it wasn't for me
no I I mean it has nothing to do with me
obviously I was when I was born my
grandfather at that time was a
politician was the lieutenant governor
of New York State stop that and he was
when I was born at a lieutenant
governor's conference in San Francisco
and the chairman of the conference was
the lieutenant governor of Kentucky and
so he announced to this whole conference
that this guy had just had his first
grandson born and that he was officially
being made a Kentucky Colonel so I have
a certificate on my wall at home that
says that I am wait thank you
stop stop I think they made you a
colonel at Birth you were born as
royalty Sean yes correct
in one session oil T you know asterisk
scroll down Kentucky yeah right but look
even the Colonel's left Kentucky you
know what I mean yeah like why now just
followed him on the chicken bucket and
every comic is dressed up like the
colonel Holly the king colonel Otto's
commercials I love it when you wouldn't
steal it but I like it when it's George
Hamilton and he's the date fraud Carl
that is fun yeah when he's extra crispy
I want to play the colonel so anyway I
want to go to the cadet video reading
yeah that's no it is and I'll tell you
it's a I I have not been back in have
you go in 20s yes okay so when I was
younger my grandfather we went all the
time
but I'll tell you one of the great ones
if you want to get like just the vibe is
that opening weekend in Keeneland so at
Lexington if you ever played that club
which is an amazing club comedy off
Broadway there is a where all the horses
kind of train and learn it's an area
called Keeneland an opening weekend
which is right about now in Keeneland is
one of the most amazing horse
experiences I highly recommend you to
it's painfully affordable and go do it
that's just as cool but only really
people in the south know to go do
Keeneland and you can bring your own
cooler honey huh bring your own cooler
BYOC box alright while we have you here
in Bergen and we're gonna do a feel-good
moment of the week we're let's do let's
do predict wild predictions let's start
will end with baseball but let's start
with this know right now are you do you
watchin the we were talking about the
Knicks earlier that's the NBA NBA just
started and I just I wanted to get some
quick thoughts on do we just fast
forward to a Golden State Cleveland
here's what I want to do because
obviously there's a total realignment of
forces on the one west side on the
Eastern Conference
now that Hayward just went out leg
injury which was so brutal I think they
should do it how they do the WNBA now
where they just take the top 10 12 team
ever from both conference put him 1 to
10 put him 1 to 12 feet everybody
and then seat everybody and there's your
playoffs because if there's such a
disparity they totally up because there
was an Eastern disparity for so long now
there's a Western disparity and it feels
like that should be that should be the
especially now so we have snoozefest
this season back in the Golden State
Cleveland I agree I kind of agree
which is what's coming yes it's just
it's already I mean you think numbers
are for now and they just they'd
literally like playing like they will be
82 and oh at the end of the season
statistical sample I know it's small but
the Lakers are their cheerleaders to the
other spirit therefore they're all the
Celtics fan I like this put the doc know
Celtics Larry Bird what do you mean oh
right now yeah Lakers oh yeah you keep
that dog in your arms in a wire like the
Clippers the reason I kind of root for
the Clippers is a kid that grew up with
played pool Richardson he was in the he
lived in our neighborhood and aperture
projects he went he played for UCLA
he was a real like inner-city project
kid and we had a playground that
separated our neighborhoods like the
projects were on one side we were on the
other side and they would come and we
would always play basketball you know
everybody plays basketball that's how
they keep the peace sports or whatever
so he was amazing as a kid he's my
brother Johnny's age don't get on the
sled too big you're too big anyway so he
but him and Johnny played football and
basketball and we used to sit and watch
him like and then he played for the
Clippers this was a long time ago but he
got hurt and now he's in the corporate
so I kind of like yeah yeah you know
obviously you guys know Alonzo Bodden
he couldn't episode he is like die hard
die die hard livers and he's got like
the best joke cuz you know he's like a
real like masculine muscular black dude
giant and they always tries to convince
people that he did play for the Clippers
people don't know leave it yeah and he
did play ball at one point in time it's
like my favorite thing about him well
there's so many favorite things here's
one quick
all right let's do do World Series
predictions and then a Phoenix shout out
a couple feel-good moments of the week
what do you think we're heading into
Game five
- - who's gonna win I say Dodgers in 7
Dodgers in 7 I say Dodgers and 6 I say
Dodgers in 6 we're sticking with Dodgers
and 6 Dodgers in gone Dodgers a7 Aaron I
want 72 change in years what was yours
last week I keep refusing the pick oh
thank you your and he's still not
allowed to and I appreciate you for that
I don't trust people who don't pick no
no he's doing that aren't doing that out
of everyone he picked it falls to [ __ ]
yes yes you anymore terrible gambler no
no no I my team didn't make it this year
and then I picked the Diamondbacks to go
all the way and here's a I'm picking the
Diamondbacks in seven okay you heard it
here first
one quick I just this is why I love
doing this podcast and when I travel for
stand-up as we both do I go see a game
anywhere I can and and I also like to
talk to all like locals because they're
look when I get like a cab driver anyone
where I could talk about their
interpreter or whatever their fandom for
their their City and their team so I was
talking to this guy he brought us from
the airport to the hotel we were talking
about I said the Phoenix sounds he's
like oh he's like there's the stadium I
said oh the Phoenix sends it they still
have a team you know joking around cuz
they're terrible I said woman nick-san
and I go one of these days Knicks are
gonna play the Suns
and he goes don't hold your breath and
he goes the Phoenix Suns you know he's
like the Phoenix Suns that they're
searching right now they're searching
for their identity much like the City of
Phoenix okay all right he got voted
solid commentary about the City of
Phoenix and the Phoenix Suns was that a
lift
or a neighbor no that was proper car sir
that was Andy Kirkman's car service that
we got into the back of they were
rolling with Kirkman
she's at the Palomar the rest of us are
following you back to motel 6 alright
we're gonna do feel-good moment of the
week do we do we and and then we shout
out to Stacy at Bedford winery
oh we're gonna email her personally back
but she gave us this great email and
we'll send you back our personal emails
because I went through all things comedy
admin al Madrigal actually forwarded it
to me but she wants to send it I like
that al is checking all the emails I
like he's aware with trust read it I
don't want to read it just in case
there's information that got it but she
was super sweet and we appreciate her
and she wants to send us some wine
Dodger wine the owner of the winery that
she works for is a massive Dodger fan
and I've actually bought this wine it's
wonderful by the way I bought the Pinot
Noir it's I'm gonna mess up the how you
say it but it's qu PE so Q pay maybe but
he private labels for Dodger Stadium so
they actually have at the Dodger logo
all of its very cute
and she said we'd love to you know send
you some great I'm so it was really
sweet so we thank you so much Stacey and
we will take you up on that girl yeah
we'll take you up on it
also it's full circle because we were
doing the Dodger game while you were
emailing us about wine so it's a circle
circle feel good him over the week we
like to do I always end it with a
feel-good moment of the week because
North Korea is a missile and
everything's on fire
wow this crowd is pouring in towards the
end crazy but we have to and they kind
of coordinate they kind of coordinates
around the Houston Dodgers series and
the first one was sent to us by Melissa
Fenton so Thank You Melissa for sending
the story do you want to take it away do
you want to lead us through this yes I'm
old Melinda wait I don't have that one
pulled up I have the other homeboy okay
well I'll do that one later it's in a
nutshell I think I posted the story if
not I will post this story but it's just
the sweetest story of a family that lost
they have two boys they lost one of
their sons to like a freak
ATV accident backyard yes they live in
Houston
and the fun there you know months and
morning and the father was like you know
what I'm just gonna buy some tickets for
the game six in Game seven against the
Yankees and they had and and they didn't
want to go because you know they were
missing their son and anyway it's a long
story but the first game they're sitting
behind the third-base coach he's wearing
and the third-base coach is wearing
number 53 and that was their son's
baseball number and so it was all all
these like 53 like there was an another
player had a jersey on but it was
they're saying like how they really felt
him his presence then Game seven they're
sitting in the front row right field and
that was a home run by Carlos Correa and
the little kid caught it it was the one
when Aaron Judge goes back for it goes
over the glove hits his glove and the
mother was like the foul ball hit him
the dad and the mother and it felt like
it was like somebody real and it brought
him so much joy and and then all the
Astros reached out to the little kid and
want to give him tickets and Korea gave
him his bat and it it was just you know
I still wish no one okay
spoken like a true New Yorker I'm sure
New Yorker I totally wish the Yankees
had money but I'm so good people and
then this morning I'm watching CNN and
this sweet little 94 year old man who is
been a die-hard Astros fan his entire
existence on this earth swayed since
AIG's well since they existed on this
earth we back that up and he really
wanted to go and couldn't get tickets
couldn't afford tickets and the story
he's what daughter his a granddaughter
put the story on Facebook had him do a
little video in a fan in Pennsylvania
who had tickets just sent the 94 year
old man his tickets and I was all see
how Pennsylvania can be nice sometimes
[Laughter]
once in a while the state of
Pennsylvania I'll be just somewhere out
in the burbs I'm gonna put on some aging
makeup and make my own video
one of these Dodger Dodger tickets I'm
gonna I do have a bad back for playing
Division three basketball husband all
right you guys full circle I love each
of you do we forget anything do you know
we have a lot of thank yous first of all
Shawn Conroy you're a dream where can
people find you at Shawn Conroy on
Twitter at Shawn it's easy and you're
about to start traveling so people can
see you
I'm going on the road for a couple
months all right follow Shawn Conroy at
at Shawn Conroy fantastic stand-up comic
and you're gonna be teaching and you're
gonna be just really just just full-on
cheering for the Knicks yes come on
zinger come on zinger
Eleanor Carrigan yes where can people
find you and hunt you down I prefer not
safely it's just EJ Carrigan on Twitter
and Facebook what I'm not doing snapchat
I can't Instagram I have that filter
night girls I'll be weird I don't need
any ears as always Erin Keith Foley comm
Trish Suhr comm you know all our
information will were reposted we just
want to say a huge thank you to all
things comedy this festival fantastic
stand applied Tempe improv Chico Malo
Bud Light
Tito's handmade vodka and of course you
would go to all things comedy comm so
you can subscribe to any and all of our
podcasts and of course YouTube to see
live-streaming if you watch this on that
you should subscribe at YouTube to be
able to watch all of us and a huge thank
you to Aaron in above dying barrel Carol
just walked through the door as we're
wrapping all that Jeter oh my god she's
got part of the artificial turf of the
Arizona Cardinals Stadium in her hair
trick question it's natural grass sports
with all balls fans
friends family have the best week of
your life